Jersey Shore's Mike the situation
Sorrentino this beautiful life Lauren
thank you guys for joining us so much
and I want to start right off and find
out how you're doing because I know you
just had a very tough no pun intended
situation yeah with the miscarriage
we're doing okay you know we he leads
our family by example with going through
our past and he I looked at him lost and
I'm like I know what to do I don't know
how to recover from this yeah and he you
just kept doing like the next right
thing
you're still trying you're gonna try yes
and that's a good situation we're gonna
keep trying yeah I also want to talk
about your sobriety we are turning four
years clean and sober right now and we
partner with onion treatment centers
okay to spread awareness about the
disease of addiction and substance abuse
if you were addicted to prescription
meds
it was one of the hardest things I've
ever done in my life you looked at your
wife would what did that because she
could see secrets so speak on it because
I went in the trenches with she believed
in me when I didn't believe in myself
you look at this man now and now what do
you think of this man he's the man I
always knew he was inside of him it's
just he finally believed in himself
enough to be that person 100% of the
time I'm still an addict and there's a
stigma about addicts but I'm changing
the game okay I'm addicted to being my
best self now I'm addicted to living my
best life my beautiful wife work being
grateful you know so that's what it is
I'm trying to teach others to do the
same